[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
March six,
2017 what's going on everybody?
I am in Phoenix, Arizona.
I'm isn't that exciting. Scenic Arizona.
Um, it actually is madam psyched.
I'm working at stand up live doing
two shows tonight, two shows Tuesday,
two shows Wednesday. Um, um, you know,
I'm putting together my new hour and
everything and I got a bunch of shit.
I've actually been listening
to my act. I always, you know,
when I'm putting together a
new hour, oh, I always record.
I just never fucking listen. Well
now I'm finally listening to my act.
I figured it out when I can do it cause
I've who the fuck months to sit there
and listen to yourself,
but I'm doing is I'm uh,
I listened to it on the car ride home.
Yeah.
You know, if I had a decent
set, if I had a shitty set,
what's the fucking point?
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like if
you're always taping you
okay
your team, right. But you only
watch if they win. You know?
I know people who do
that shit. They like, no,
what the fuck happens before
they watch it and if they lose,
they just don't even fucking watch.
So I've actually been watching
and that type of shit. And uh,
speaking of which you're team winning
and losing all the freckles came in,
uh, last night and I went to
the Phoenix Suns were playing,
my boss did sell decks. So
I decide, you know what,
I'm going to go to that game. All right.
My hundred and 17th fucking
franchise professional home team.
I've fought ever professional sports team
that I've seen a home game of hundred
and fucking 17 of these
motherfuckers. I got 10 more to go.
I can't get on any 10. Every time I get
to 10. And I'm like, oh, one more team.
I'll fucking, then I'll have nine
left and somebody moves, you know,
I got down to 10. I'm like, all right,
the next one's going to get me down
to nine and then the fucking ramp,
the rams move back up to 11. Right.
So then I go see the thunder and I'm
thinking, all right, look man, I'm down.
I'm down to fucking, I'm
down to nine and I'm like,
wait a minute.
Yeah,
Okay.
I saw the New Jersey Nets. I never saw
the Brooklyn Nets soda. It's still 10.
So I'm like, all right, next week,
next week when I go see the sons,
I'll be down to 19th left, right?
So I'm sitting there watching
the sons and I'm like Verizon,
I'm down to single digits.
The Fan Slam is going down.
One of the loneliest accomplishments ever.
I guess if you went with
a bunch of other people,
I got to find the old pictures of me
at these stadiums. I swear to God,
they're all like disposable camera
pictures held by a stranger. Um,
you know,
when I was doing all these fucking
gigs in the middle of nowhere and shit,
and I pass through the major cities
and I would just go to a Goddamn game
anyways. So last night
I'm thinking, all right,
I'm going to the son's Celtics game.
I'll have nine teams left. And I'm like,
wait a minute. The fucking charges
just moved the Los Angeles.
So
in a month I'm working in San Antonio
and I'm going to a spurs game,
go into the fuck and spurs and then
I think I'll finally be down to nine.
You know, God forbid if the
fucking Raiders don't move
to Vegas after that. Um,
but anyways, I uh, I went
to the sun's game, right?
So I show up immediately. Um, the
club hooked us up with tickets,
gave us great ticks. We sit in two rows
buying the fucking one, one of the, uh,
what do you call it in basketball?
One of the nets, one of the goals,
one of the backboards,
right? Two, two rows back.
So it's really three rows back cause
they got all the fucking cameraman,
you know, but still it's like great seats.
And I looked down on the right and is
this guy just riding the reps in the,
in the first quarter? And
he really gives a shit.
So I'm looking at [inaudible] and
I'm just looking over going, look,
this fucking, this guy's out of his
mind. That is a guy who gives a shit.
This is a hardcore season ticket
holder, man. Look how much he,
and I'm laughing like he's just
like, he knows the refs names,
he's calling them out and all that shit
in verge. He starts going, he goes,
I bet that's the owner. I'm like, Nah,
I'm going to own it
wouldn't be sitting down.
He would be yelling like that if he
was the owner. And he's like, well,
Mark Cuban writes the reps like that. I
go get the fuck out of here. So finally,
you know, I go, I man, I'm going to
look this guy up, right? So we've,
we look them up and it's the owner.
I gotta to tell you, Phoenix Suns, dude,
you guys got a great fucking owner.
Uh, Robert Sarver is his name, man.
We ended up talking to him at the
end of the game cause I tweeted a,
I was making fun of, um, what's
his face, his shoes, his sneakers,
the fucking worst sneakers
I've ever fucking seen. Um,
Kelly Olynyk, the big white goof,
the seven foot fucking
pylon out there, right?
I don't, I, you know, Celtics love that
guy. Ain't he got so many Goddamn meds.
Maybe it's a road trip
or whatever, but do this.
He had these fucking sneakers on,
I think Garo your premium warm in there.
That fucking Superbowl
against the Redskins.
When he fucked up the field
goal two, they were like,
they look like black football cleats
from the early seventies the ugliest
fucking things I've ever seen.
So of course I tweet about that.
That's why I get,
so I tweeted about the thing and I guess
the owner's son was watching. He goes,
oh, he's probably sitting right
next to you, blah, blah blah.
That's how he didn't mean the guy.
But anyways, long story short,
so I tweet about this fucking things,
making fun of the guy's sneakers thinking.
Obviously these have to be the worst
fucking sneakers. Without a doubt.
Even with the Internet, even with Twitter,
even with all of these fucking
cons that are on social media,
nobody can argue with that. These are
the ugliest fucking sneakers ever, right?
They will low top fucking feel.
Go kick a cleats on the
fucking early seventies right.
And all these sneaker
heads are like, you mean,
you mean the Colby eleven's
I guess just the Colby
Bryan sneaker. And what?
Because it says Colby on it. All
of a sudden it's the coal piece.
Do do you mean the shack fourteens
I fucking hate sneaker heads,
but fucking can't stay at them with
the 5,000 fucking pairs of sneakers,
taking him out of the box, showing them
off on MTV cribs and licking the soul.
So it's like, you see, I never, we, I
never even wore these joints before.
Okay.
Yeah. I can tell from your fucking man
tits she never worn before this sneakers.
Why don't you go take a fucking walk
in them versus a big sneaker head?
I'll tell you,
you know what it is fucking overrated
is so fucking overrated Jordans.
You know what I mean? I'm not saying
they're not good. Look at some of them.
Most of them are fucking
ugly as shit and dude,
the fucking mouth breathing
dope. Maybe that's what it is.
The amount of fuck up. Geez,
I'm walking around now.
I'm walking through the amount of
fucking dokes that we're Jordans.
You know what it is about Jordans. It's,
you don't even have to fucking think.
Okay.
You know what I mean? All you
gotta do is get a pair of Jordans.
You know everybody's gonna like him. Oh,
y'all were those the 60s are those the
Jordan six is to look at these sections.
I've got them with the black, with
the gold outline. John d, The these,
these sneakers are crazy,
right? These things are crazy.
Okay?
Yeah. I don't know.
Fucking mouth breathing morons with
the Goddamn sweatpants in the Jordans.
You know furs? He's a big Jordan
Guy. He loves Jordans. He was,
he's wearing a pair of this week.
They're fucking ugly. His Shit.
Okay.
They're all black.
And then they got like this white wall
tire thing done it just because it says
Jordan, I'm gonna go. Paul was to check
out these new George. You like them?
I go, no, I actually, I don't, and he
can't understand. He goes, we would be
the Jordans Dude. These, these, these
are Jordan. Once. It's like, dude,
I don't give a fuck at the Jordan
night. I'm so sick of the numbers.
Okay.
Do. What's your favorite Jordans?
You like to seven's really?
You like to sevens that you gotta make
sure that that it just says Nike on the
back. If it has him on the back,
then those aren't the real ones.
Okay.
The Kobe 11
okay.
Like what do you guys think
that if you fucking put them on,
you're somehow going to be able to dunk.
You're going to score close to 80 points
in a fucking NBA game cause you're
wearing cobis the Sundale three seven.
I don't know. I don't understand
if a fucking sneakers ugly. It's
ugly. I don't give a shit [inaudible]
I cannot fucking believe you guys.
You have to go on and you have to look
at a picture of those fucking sneakers.
They like referees sneakers from the
fucking early eighties it's just a black
low top fucking slipper
with the Nike swoosh on it.
Yeah.
Do you mean the Kobe 11 do the
Colby eleven's of fucking crazy.
The crazy Tony. You get yourself,
you get yourself a fucking tracksuit and
you put on a pair of those dude over.
Oh, you go out to the club people.
People are, are those the sixes?
Okay.
I, I don't, I just don't understand
fucking basketball sneakers. Okay.
Some of a good look and some
of them aren't just a, they,
they drive me up the
fucking wall. Paul Vars,
he's the funniest fucking human being
I've ever met in my life. Like he's, he's,
he's one of these guys, like I love him
to death, but the shit that he likes,
it's so, he likes obvious shit. It'd
be like, dude, do you know what I like?
You know what I like? I like amenities.
Okay.
It's like, really, dude, you like getting
extra shit, extra comforting shit out.
It's amazing. You know? I never really
thought about that. I don't know.
I have to think about
this. Do I like amenities?
You know what? I like Paul. I like a
lack thereof. I'd like less than like,
who would ever say that? Dude?
You know what? You know what I do?
Is there anything better than pizza?
Is there anything better than
a great slice, a piece of do?
Do you know what I like?
I like a Bologna Sandwich.
Okay.
Do a Bologna sandwich with white American
cheese and mustard due to the mustard,
puts it over the top. It's
crazy. It's a joke. I mean,
it's literally a joke. It just,
I dunno.
Yeah.
So it's like, does it even need to be
said? Of course it's a Bologna Sandwich.
Yeah, it fucking hits the spot.
Well, mainstream Polly, dude.
You know what I like, you know I
like, I like a golden retriever.
Do you know what's crazy?
A white picket fence.
I'm sorry, I gotta get him
back on this podcast cause I w
Hartnett calls him Mr Maxim cause
everything that he likes, it's like, it's,
he likes what everybody likes,
but then she's got this simplistic
fucking great philosophy. We'll,
he'll be like, Bill,
but bill, what's wrong?
What's wrong with sweat pants? You
know, and you can't argue with them.
Exactly. There's, there's nothing
wrong with that. It's just, you know,
the conversation is just like,
it just doesn't need to be,
most of the conversation just
doesn't even need to be had to,
is there anything better than
just walking around in sweatpants?
Dude,
you put on a pair of sweatpants
with some Jordan threes over over
to what is better than have it on
a Hoodie and a pair of Colby 11.
You go to a massage parlor and she's
jerking your Dick. I mean [inaudible].
Oh Man. Am I crazy? I said, so
it's, it's short. It's literally,
it's a joke. All right.
I'm sorry. Fuck all you
sneaker heads out there.
God bless you with your
little fucking hobby. Uh,
keeping your sneakers clean and you know,
fucking walking on your heels anytime
there's any sort of rubbish on the ground
ground. Fucking men just walking
like a Goddamn duck on their heels.
Hey Buddy, what the fuck
do I got on this seven?
What is it? The first day of school,
Dude, you know what I
love? You know what I love?
Is there anything better than
when it snows on Christmas?
That's the type of shit he says. It's
like, no. Yeah, it is. It's great. Paul.
I think everybody's pretty much in
agreement. I even think Jewish people,
like if it snows on Christmas,
you know what I mean?
It probably adds to their
Chinese food. I don't,
where could have fuck doesn't like a fresh
blanket of snow as long as it isn't a
God damn storm.
Dude. You know what I, I like amenities.
Is there anything better than
taking a steam? Uh, no. I mean,
you know, that's also, that is a great
thing that everyone is in agreement with.
You don't want to like,
dude, I like fresh air.
Is there anything better than like non
polluted air when you breathe in? I mean,
it's crazy. It's a joy.
It's literally, it's a joke.
Um, Jesus, I went on a
fucking tangent there.
Oh my gosh. I have to second. I
thought the recorder wasn't recording.
I forgot my fucking microphone. So
this might sound a little bit, dude.
Is there anything better?
Did Jess Lan in your bed and just
waking up and doing your podcast?
I mean, it's a joy. It's literally,
it's, it's, it's a joke. You know,
I have to look up these fucking
sneakers. How the Fuck Koby Bryant,
one of the greatest fucking top of
what, two or three players of all time,
individual players, teammates.
He was a fucking nightmare. Um,
you went to that fucking
confessional comes up. Um,
let me sit down, put in my password here.
Stupid Laker fans that
we, Chan MVP at the guy.
I hate that Celtic fans are chanting
MVP at Isaiah Thomas. By the way,
it reminds me of Laker
fans that were always,
every time fucking Colby stepped on
the court and did not pass the ball and
scored 40 fucking points
and they lose again.
And they did have VAPI. Um,
did you see him dunk on that guy
and then they lost? Oh my God,
he's unbelievable.
Maybe if we get 58 free agents
in here and fucking Phil Jackson,
they can win a title and v p all right.
I'm not what he's doing.
He's wearing the Colby sees
where we're in the Kobe left.
I have to look these fucking sneakers
up. How ugly these goddamn things are.
And the fact that these sprockets,
sneaker heads, you mean the Colbys?
I mean the rep sneakers, those
fucking cleats. This guys wearer,
he looks like fucking Ken
Stabler out there. Colby 11.
You cannot tell me that this fucking, the
computer doesn't listen to you. Oh my,
those are fucking dancing slippers.
Jesus. At least to get the best.
He got the best color
[inaudible]
they come in pink becoming red and
white. They got a Miami dolphin color.
Do those literally look
like women's sneakers? Like
you should have like the low cut sock
with the little ball on the back if you
wear those fucking things. And I'm
looking, look, look at the ones
220 $130
yes.
I bet this,
I bet if I went on youtube and this and
I looked up koby 11 I bet there's some
fucking asshole sitting there
licking the fuck. Who is that guy?
Fat Joe did that and his MTV cribs. And
he goes, he had like checked, he's off.
He's like the fucking George 60th.
And then he licked the bottom of them.
It's like, dude, do you
realize the sweatshop?
But those things were fucking Baden. Yeah.
And you think those things
didn't hit the ground in there.
And God knows they probably don't.
Like they probably make those people go
to the bathroom at the fucking station
and you're gonna let the bottom
of those. Goddamn sneakers.
Okay.
They were in a hermetically
sealed sneaker box. Dude.
They were in a cardboard box and was
shipped over here from the other side of
the world. I think I'll
put my tongue on them.
Okay.
All right. I'm going to look this up.
I'm going to see if I can find that.
I'm going to find a fucking video here.
Coby 11 all right. I don't know why,
but the first video that came up set
exploding pool and a guy had shit on his
face.
Now I didn't think they did that type
of stuff on fucking Colby 11 shoes.
Alright. And some asshole's
going to do a fucking review.
Nike Colby 11 Performance Review Too.
These are the ugliest fucking
sneakers I've ever seen in my life.
These ones are actually worse.
Okay.
Colby. Bryan gives the Brian
James's autograph shoes.
God, what the fuck did they talk about
other than winning championships?
That'd be like listening to fucking
superman and like fucking Batman talking.
All right. Coby gives away shoes to a
fan. Here's a shit all over the guy.
He's like the nicest guy ever.
Colby helps a busload of sick children
get to the staples center by towing it
with his own body and his Colby
eleven's or maybe I was wrong.
Um, Nike. Kobe, I gotta get
off this fucking subject.
What am I gonna listen to some guy
do a fucking review of the sneakers.
Nike Colby 11 performance overview. My
initial thoughts. I fucking love Youtube.
Who gives us, I guess you guys
are listening to my thoughts,
but I'm just being a fucking
moron. Anyways, let's get
back to the Goddamn game.
All right, so Kelly, a Lennox out
there and is Coby eleven's dude,
they will fucking crazy, dude.
You get a seven foot
white guy and Kobe 11.
It's all, it's all,
I mean the black guys are still going
to go right around them and have their
nuts in his face when they
dunk on it, but I mean his,
his feet from the ankles down, it's,
it's always going to be a such a joke.
It's literally a joke. Um, all right.
Anyways, so we go, we watched this game.
The owner of the sons is a fucking riot.
I'm totally this watching him ride
in the referees, like old school guy,
you know, right down there on the court
watching the game and uh, you know,
he's not about some luxury box or
anything like that. Right. So anyway,
so we'll watch it in the game
and the Celtics come out flat,
which you knew they were gonna you knew
they were gonna cause they've just beat
the Lakers anytime. I'm telling you
this right now, gamblers, gamblers,
anytime the, the, any Boston team, I,
the y would say the
Bruins are the fucking uh,
Celtics going that west coast trip. Okay.
If you want to make some money,
bet against them the day after
they'd play either the, the clippers,
the kings or the Lakers,
cause they fucking go to la.
And after the game they all go out.
They Bang a bunch of fucking broads,
a bunch of fucking actresses or
whatever the fuck it is they do.
And then the next game, when they
go to San Jose, down to Anaheim,
out to Phoenix, up to Portland,
whatever the fuck they go next,
there's always a let down.
So the Celtics come out flat.
The fucking sons are all over him. Um,
love the God was on the sons was
just as fast it seems as Isaiah.
So he was right up on them. Um,
frustrating the hell out of them. He,
Isaiah had I think four files
in the first half. And um,
so we're watching the game and I'm just
going like, I fucking knew it. I've,
I'm so excited to finally see
this team. I've been watching,
seeing almost every game of this year
and they come out flat. I'm like, Oh man,
am I really going to the fucking
hangover game? Ah, what do I give a shit?
I got three fucking tickets,
but still, you know,
there's a bunch of Celtics fans there.
They're all going fucking
nuts and everything.
We had like nothing to cheer about.
I think we were down by like
10 after the first half. Um,
and we just start chipping away,
chipping away, chipping away.
First half was ugly. I mean it was like,
it was like a first quarter score
with like four minutes to go.
It was like 30 to 27 it seemed,
maybe it was like six minutes to go.
So what the half?
I think they were both like the f
forties ain't don't even remember. And a,
and I said, Paul
Jokingly, I go, you watch,
the bolt's going to score over a hundred,
they're going to eat up or whatever.
So of course they come out,
everybody starts hitting their shots,
it turns into this great game. Um,
and then the fourth quarter comes and
we start chipping away, chipping away,
chipping away with done by like 10
or 11, and then went down by eight,
then went down by five and then without
my four. And next thing you know,
we're up by like two. So you guys all
know how the fucking game ends, right?
We fucking missed what's his face? Uh,
Brown missed that foul shot
and Isaiah, Mr. Foul Shot,
that would've fucking iced it.
And uh, we let him hang around,
hang around and fucking hang around
the end. I can't remember who was tied.
We were up by one. It all
happened. So you know,
it happened so fucking fast when you're
at the game and you don't have an
announcer holding your hand and you don't
have something that you can actually
look at, there's too much shit
to look at. So we go to inbound.
The fucking ball.
Yeah,
right. This guy goes around Jae Crowder
I think tied it up with like fuck right.
That's right.
We were up by two instead of being up
by three and forcing him to take a three
and they probably would have missed
a fucking thing. That's right.
And the guy goes right around, Crowder
lays it in, crowd's going nuts.
There's like four seconds left.
The guy and I can try to get a toy.
Isaiah Thomas, let's see what
happens. We fucking inbound the ball.
Isaiah,
one of the only times I've seen him
mess up this year messed up the past.
Who's kind of looking up court, you know,
cause there's only four seconds
left before he caught the ball.
They kick it out to this fucking
dude. What the hell was his name?
I actually wrote it down so I would
give him the respect he deserves.
Tyler ulous,
they kick it out to him and he hits a
fucking three point or the buzzer to beat
the Celtics. Now here's the thing,
I had second row fucking seats.
And guess what? I didn't even see
the play. It happened on my end.
You know why?
Because the fucking assholes who were
in there in the front fucking row.
Yeah,
they inbound the ball and
they could see that, you know?
Okay.
Um, Thomas was, was fucking
it up. They stand up,
you're in the fraud. Fucking run.
What are you standing up for?
There's nothing in front
of you. You fucking cunt.
And all of a sudden I just saw the ball
go to the net and everybody goes and the
horn goes off. Everybody goes
nuts. I go, what the fuck
does that count? Did that just go
with what the fuck just happened?
I had to go home to watch the replay
to see what the fuck happened.
I was sitting in the second row.
I couldn't see it because he's fucking
assholes stood up in front of me. Um,
I don't, I don't understand standing
up when nothing's in your way.
They haven't. You ever
heard that expression?
Why stand when you could sit by
sit, when you could lay down?
Why stand up when you were in the front
fucking row and what is blocking your
God view anyways? All right, I'm done.
Fucking bitch in here. I had a a,
I had a great time and evidently
Kobe eleven's are fucking crazy man.
You know
dude, Chris Everett should wear that
fucking sneakers. That's what it looks at.
It looks like the one that different
colored ones. I'd like, you know,
do you know something that is a
testament to how great Colby Bryant was.
You know, it's almost
like he's so fucking good.
Nike was at the factory going like how
fucking ugly do you think we could make a
sneaker if we put your name on it?
These people that lick the
bottom of the fucking sneaker,
will they still buy these
goddamn things? You know what?
Now that I'm looking at
him, cause I'm an old man,
they don't look like you
played basketball. Great.
They look comfortable as hell as far
as when they're in a different color.
I guess they look like slippers.
Now here's the thing. What I want
is I want to fucking ask you.
Coby had that horrific, uh, Achilles.
Okay.
Um, injury, I swear to God, which is like,
that was the end of anybody's career.
That is like the classic
old man basketball injury
is you go to take a step in
your fucking Achilles, goes right
up the back of your leg. Um,
okay.
I mean, I don't even let me, I usually,
obviously I don't fucking play
hoop it all, but I still fucking,
I'm always stretching my fucking Achilles.
I swear to God before I
get out of bed, that's,
I don't know what it is about that injury.
I just know like five or six people that
have had it and I want no part of it.
I want no fucking, you never walk right
again. I mean, if he got Kobe's money,
you know,
you can go to Germany and meet the grand
sons of the Nazi fucking doctors and
they'll spend your fucking blood in a
centrifuge, whatever the fuck they do.
And then you come back and you can
still dunk or whatever. You know,
but most people don't have Coby
money. So what's going to happen is,
is you're going to go down
to the veterinarian down
the street and he's going to
sell that thing back and you're never
going to, you're never going to be,
you know,
that's it.
God help you.
If you're ever in a situation where
there's panic and the crowd starts running
and it's a stampede and you've blown
out your Achilles at some point in your
life that's you're going to get trampled.
You know,
you're going to be that zebra in the
Serengeti that gets eaten by the fucking
alligators, basically what's going
to happen. Um, but he, you know,
he has the low tops. I wonder if that
probably had nothing to do with it.
I'm just surprised guys are wearing low
top fucking sneakers again. Like it's a,
yeah,
cause you know, I, I don't pay attention
to shit. I usually watch hockey. Right.
And versus going like, no, no, no.
Colby kind of brought the low tops back.
Everybody's wearing.
So I looked out on the court and I saw
a number of people with low tops or
people still had like
these high top sneakers on,
but the amount of ones like that,
that they were like Velcro, you know,
like a little kitty
can't tie sneakers. See,
have they had like velcro high tops with
like a fucking belt around your ankle.
And I was,
I dunno, I dunno about those either.
You know what's hilarious?
How arrogant I am that I actually think
that the world cares what a 48 year old
white guy thinks about
fucking sneakers. Oh,
why don't you just get a pair
of shell toes? Um, so anyways,
we went to the Goddamn game and uh,
we had a great fucking
time. Um, Robert Sovereign,
his family are great. We met, we met
him briefly, but, and just talk to him,
just great people like that guy.
Dude, if I was a feed experiment,
I would be very happy with
that guy. As an owner,
even though I know you guys
are rebuilding, that guy
fucking loves his team.
There's a lot of owners, they
don't give a shit. You know,
they own a team so they can have hookers
and blow it up in a fucking sweet dude.
That guy, he was, it looked
like he, I was going to say,
it's like he had money on the game and
he does. He's paying the fucking players.
Um,
anyways. Um, all right, so
let's plow ahead here. Um,
I should probably read some God damn
advertising radio. All right, Luke Craig.
Oh, give me the loop. Uh,
be the envy of your friends.
Be The envy of your friends. Why would
you want your friends to be envious? Gee,
I wish I had what you had and get 100%
exclusive crates@lukecraig.com slash burr
and enter my code Berg to save
$3 off any new subscription.
Wait until I tell you about
marches. Crate. It's wild.
All capital letters.
Why it's wild on a quest
for epic gear, housewares,
housewares, and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fin
fanatical Fashionista,
I hate that. Fucking fanatical
Fashionista. Then try loot where?
Monthly wearables and accessories and
coke classics and your favorite franchise.
Oh, with your coke classics
and your favorite franchises.
Um,
what fanatical fashion. He said,
what the fuck does that mean?
Offer expires March 19th at 9:00 PM.
That roar in the distance is
a call. Will you answer it?
This month we're going primal
and unleashing the beast
of some of pop culture's
most ferocious franchises. They
love alliteration with the efs.
Fucking fantastic. This march experience,
iconic items from Overwatch, Wolverine,
Jurassic World and Predator, including
as always our monthly tee shirt and pin.
Go to Luke craig.com/burn.
Enter my code burr to save $3 off
on any new subscription today.
Hey nerds, I don't know what the fuck
that, I don't even know what that is.
Do you guys have a dental?
He love it and you're buying this shit
cause they keep advertising on my podcast
. I know what Predator is.
I know what Wolverine is.
That's when that Australian guy has to
eat a whole fucking chicken day to get
jacked. And I was reading
the other day, that guy,
he's played wolverine eight times and
he has to pack on like 25 pounds of
fucking muscle. He goes,
I eat a whole chicken every day because
my jaw is literally sore from eating.
It's like, why don't you
just do Royce? You know,
it's not like they test
you as an actor. Oh,
did you hear about the fucking wolverine?
Gay can't make any more movies.
He got suspended for three
movies. He did steroids. Um,
[inaudible] Oh, Bodo boat boat me on
these me is watching the Phoenix Suns.
But Dude, dude, dude, me undies me
undies, Atlantic is a fucking bomb.
He's fucking seven feet.
I don't give a fuck.
He's got the lateral movement of a fucking
dump truck. I don't know what to say.
Anyway,
your balls will feel nice and fucking
soft when you're wearing the Colby 11.
They're fucking ugly. Um, meet me on this.
The lateral movement of a dump
truck. I know it does. Whatever.
It fucking rhymed. You can
at least get me that Mandy,
she was one of the following
openers in your read. Okay.
Elevate your underwear game to
the next level with me undies.
Um,
you've perfected your wardrobe,
but what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if
you've been settled. Dude,
is there anything better
than a new pair of underwear?
Okay.
I mean, it's crazy. Your
balls are alive, you know,
do you have on a new pair of underwear
and, and you have the Olynyk sevens on.
I'm telling you, dude, and you go to,
is there anything better than a bowl
of fucking great nuts? Um, great nuts,
right? You fucking, you. You're
nuts are fucking comfortable.
Your grape nuts are a soft you
touch. It's going to be a great day.
You put on your sweat pants, you
get a slice of pizza. You know,
somebody says something, you go, Oh,
if you'd been settling for store
bought underwear, five packs,
I have something that will change
your life for the better me on this.
What's the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off,
it's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me on undies.
What is me on these? Oh,
just seriously soft and feel good on
these delivered right to your door.
Biondi you've be funny as of Kelly.
Olynyk actually hears this and kicks me
in my red nuts with this fucking Kobe 11
so that would really be justice. There's
your lateral movement. You're wanting,
your balls is going this way.
The others go on the other way.
You know something. That's why
I think you have a ball bag.
You know what I mean? Cause it hurts
so much to get kicked in the balls.
God had to give your balls the
opportunity to try to get out of the way.
You know what I mean? It's like a running
back that knows how to take a hit.
You know you can't have
like, like Earl Campbell,
just one in straight up and down.
You're going to end up in a fucking
wheelchair. You know what I mean?
I know Jim Brown doesn't like it,
but these running backs that step out
of bounds, they prolong your career.
That's what your balls are doing
and your ball back. All right,
back to the book. Copy. Hear me.
UNDIES are designed in La. Oh Jesus.
And made from sustainably
sourced micro modal, modal R.
It's a fabric three
times softer than cotton.
Evidentaly eat me undies softer
than socks. Loves undies.
Isn't that supposed to
be luxury? Lux? See Luke,
say undies come in an ever changing
selection of classic colors.
Maybe you can find some to match your
Jordan sixes do to say anything better
than walking around in your underwear
and you find some Jordan's sevens that
match. I mean, it's fucking crazy.
If you're wearing a bathrobe and you
smoking a cigar, I mean, dude, it's over.
It's a joke. It's literally a joke. Um,
Yonnie's softer than Sa. Is there a
does anything better than free porn? Um,
bold shades and advertise
it. Adventurous patterns.
You can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready
for a subscription, that's
okay. You can still save.
That's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL me
undies.com/bar and get
20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it. Once again, that's me
on.com/bar [inaudible] dot com
slash Berg oh Jay's is. Here we go.
Oh my God. Dollar Shave
Club. Everybody. You know,
and I'm going to read one more
of these cause I got three left.
I want to take a break.
You know what I mean?
I can't be fucking reading
all these Goddamn ads.
Dolly Shaped Club don't,
there's no reason to use a cheap
disposable fucking raise. Uh Oh.
Pay ridiculously high prices kid for
some gimmicky fucking thing that's got a
laser pointed with 17 blades.
Make this mad at choice.
Make the Markus choice.
Make the smarter choice and Join Dollar
Shave Club before dollar shave club.
It was either save money and get a painful
shave from a dispose disposables like
the one they give away
for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece
of glass or you pay a fortune for the
latest gimmicky shave breakthrough.
You don't need like a laser
chin detector or 17 more blades.
Yeah, do the only thing you two
blades. One blade sucked, right?
It's one of my in lady shaving my legs
over here. Two blades was the shit.
Three, three blades and on fucking
terrific. It just got too big.
He couldn't get underneath.
He knows and I got a cute little button
nose it even I had a problem, you know,
can't imagine somebody was one of
them. Them Roman noses, you know,
one of those gladiator
noses, Mediterranean.
I can't say the obvious choice here
because everybody would get offended,
but you know what I mean? Those poor
people, what they've been through.
Can you imagine that all of a sudden
there's this fucking three blades? I mean,
does the suffering ever end?
Yeah.
Get a close,
smooth shave every time and you can't
beat the convenience or the price of the
club if you haven't tried dollar
shave club yet, you're missing out.
The fuck is this. I set
my alarm for 8:00 AM.
Why would I do that? Oh,
I know why I got to pick up the rental
car and I forgot I had to do my podcast,
but I just woke up like a God damn
machine knowing wait a minute,
I gotta do my podcast. Um,
get a close shave, close,
smooth shave every time.
And you can't beat the convenience of
the price if you haven't tried dollar
shave club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave
at an affordable price.
There's no smarter choice in the market.
And right now that giving away what one
month trial for any of their raises for
a dollar with free shipping. After
that, it's just a few bucks a month.
A, there's no longterm
commitments, no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want. Uh,
get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bar that's dollar shave
club.com/burr. All
right. Okay, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go. Let's
get back to the fucking podcast.
So I've been listening to a bunch
of fucking old school country,
not all the way back to Hank Williams,
but like that outlaw shit, you know,
right before the outlaws. Shit is
George Jones considered outlaw,
I dunno, but listening
to him late, obviously,
um, to all of these other
fucking guys, right. And uh,
I ended up listing, I
remember that the song,
do you guys remember Johnny paycheck?
Johnny paycheck was this country
singer and he, I swear to God,
he had a hit song called
take this job and shove it.
And it was such a fucking hit.
It's so struck a chord with people that
they actually turned it into a movie.
There was actually a movie called take
this job and shove it. It was just a,
it was about a fucking guy who was working
in a job that he hated and he wanted
to tell him, you know, basically
tell him to go fuck themselves.
But he didn't have the nerves.
And I think it was because the lyric was
someday I'm going to get the nerve to
say it and everybody could
relate to it being like, Hey,
I also hate my fucking life
and I want to make a change,
but I don't know how to do
it. You know what I mean?
It's like the whole Donald Trump fucking
phenomenon, not the informed people.
You know what I mean? I'm talking
about the, the, the mouth breather.
You know what I mean? Like
what the Hillary Clinton,
you had the informed person that wanted
to vote for her and then you had the
hissy fit, fucking dope.
This will be great for women.
Like your life was really gonna
fucking change. Um, I swear to God, I,
I just don't, I don't,
I don't understand adults who haven't
fucking figured it out yet. That you're,
you're on your own. Okay. Play time
is over. Nobody cares about you. Okay.
I don't care what color they're fucking
tired them for. Their Bra is they,
they don't,
the level of money that you have to have
and then you have to give it to these
people to, for you to
even be on their radar,
you have to be going to these 10,000,
a hundred thousand $50,000
fucking plate dinners with them.
And then you have to stand in a line
of people that all paid that money.
Okay? And you got to get up there with
your fucking shapeshift or fucking lizard
eyeballs and you got to try
to appear into their soul.
I didn't think you'd talk to him.
You just walk up with a Napkin that says
how much money are you going to give to
them? And then you're
on their fucking radar.
Has nothing to do with your
genitalia anyways, so all the, okay,
so I'm getting off the rails yet. So
this fucking guy, Johnny paycheck,
he's got this fucking shot. The song
called take this job and shove it.
It's the funniest fucking, just,
there's no way to listen to this
song and not fucking just be,
I played it for Paul Versey. He
was crying, laughing. He goes,
this can't be a real song. I go,
dude, not only is it a real song,
I was turned into a movie.
Just the way he says, shove it,
his voice drops way down. He goes,
take this job and shove it.
I work in here no more.
My woman Don lab took all the reasons why
I was working for these are the actual
lyrics.
You better or not try to stay in the
my way cause I'm walking out the door.
You could take this job I working here
no more than the stupid baseline comes on
boot but du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du
and it gets all like [inaudible]
kind of quiet. You don't
want to red neck gets quiet,
you know and starts talking,
leans in. It's fucking scary.
You know non Whitey. Even for
white people. That's fucking scary.
There is nothing scarier than a redneck
leaning in at a bar thinking that you
were all on the same team.
That's some fucked up shit cause you're
immediately like, I don't want to do,
I don't, I don't want any part of what
you're about ready to tell me sir.
And I want to try to get out of
this conversation gracefully.
How do I dismount out of
this fucking conversation?
The second they went on a fucking
redneck looks the opposite way of the
conversation and then
leans in. I'm telling you,
this should be like a fucking an injector
seat on your bar stool to get you the
fuck out of it. Where did it
go? Did I get left behind?
Um, so I swear to God. So when he
gets into the verse, right? He,
it's like he's leaning in
happy and working in this
factory for now on 15 years
all his time.
Or Watch my woman drowning in
a pool that tears. You know,
and I,
what I love about all those old school
country songs is it fucking women always
leave. They're always crying or
whatever, but these fucking assholes,
they never say why. And whenever I listen
to these songs, it's just like, dude,
what the fuck are you doing? I get
it. You're working at this factory.
You don't like the job. Why is your woman
drowning in a pool of tears? What the,
I mean, are you taking this
fucking, so you don't have the balls
to try to get a better job? Tell your
boss to fuck off. So what happens?
You come home, you take it out on
your wife. Is that what you're doing?
I bet. Shit jobs. I've had law
pay up for the first fucking,
I don't know how many years of being
a comedian. Was it a low paying job?
I never had a girlfriend
drown in a pool of tears.
I mean, I definitely made him cry,
but that's because I was an asshole.
Had nothing to do with my
fuck. I wouldn't blame my job.
Okay.
I've been featuring on the road for
now on 16 years on of these days.
Anyways. You got, you just listen to the
fucking song. You gotta hear this song,
you gotta you, um, Johnny paycheck. Um,
I know I'm making fun of
him, but I actually, I dunno,
there's something about this.
I listened to this fucking song and
just gives me all kinds of ideas for
characters and shit like that
and movies and whatever. Um,
but I'm in download, George Jones,
George Jones. Tammy way net,
all of these fucking
people, and I swear to God,
you got to, you got to listen
to George Jones these days.
These days I barely get by
is inadvertently one of
the funniest buckets.
Songs you ever gonna listen to your life.
Do you have one of those friends that
just calls up and complains all the time
and you, you try to help them out and
go, hey, well what if you do? Nah,
I can't do that. And one blow the
fucking guy who just resigned himself.
Okay,
yeah. Hey, with my lot, this
would x, Y, and z would happen.
That's why I can't with
that fucking attitude,
that's exactly what's going to happen.
Okay?
You know what I mean? I've got
a couple of friends like that.
After awhile you just like, dude,
you're a white guy and the
United States of America.
How far down the fucking track before
the race starts that you have to be
Jesus fucking Christ? How the
fuck are you complaining? I'm
complaining. I'm not saying that white
people should not complain. Okay.
I know there's a lot of people down
in a pool. It tears harder these days.
I'm going to get the, I'm going
to blow my top. It's like, dude,
why don't you just address the
fact that you don't like your job?
Apply from some other jobs. If
you don't have the training,
take some night courses. You know,
get the training you need instead of
sitting there seething coming home,
taking it out on your fucking well.
George Jones has another fucking
song called the grand tour.
I listened to that. I'm telling you, you
got to listen to these fucking songs,
right? I listened to that
song. It's like, George,
what in the fuck did you do
to your woman? It's like,
step right up. Come on in.
If you'd want to tag the Grand Tor, Oh,
below where? How's the
woods was home. Sweet home.
You're like, Jesus Christ
and this motherfucker. He
goes through his whole house
over there.
Okay.
It is the chair where it should bring the
pipe to me and sit down on my knee and
whisper, Ooh, I love you.
I you're like Jesus Christ right there.
You want to get out of the house?
This motherfucker won't
stop straight ahead.
It is the bed where we lay low, boom. So
thought he gets all away to
the nursery. You're like,
oh Jesus Christ. He goes,
she took the fucking baby and the key
thing in all of this is he says there's a
rings and a things and it's
like this fucking woman
[inaudible]
left all of her stuff and
took the baby. George,
what the fuck did you do to him?
Okay,
this woman didn't leave you.
She fled the fucking scene.
There's some sort of detail [inaudible]
you're not fucking given me here.
Where are the empty booze bottles? I
mean, what do you, what do you, what did
I actually listened to that song?
I feel bad for the woman in his
life until I found out she left.
Then I actually feel good. Yeah,
get the fuck out I and get that kid out
of there told me that if I'm supposed to
feel bad for you.
Okay.
Sounds like you went out back to
chop some wood and she just grass.
She saw some daylight, somehow got the
chains off around her fucking ankles,
grabbed the kid and get the fuck
out of there. Um, anyway, so
[inaudible]
Oh, there's going to be some pure
country fans are gonna be like,
you're missing the point, man.
Take this job and show that
night working here in more.
Alright. Pro Flowers. Everybody.
Wallman Boon blessed me.
Okay.
My woman Doug, left me. Hey
Johnny paycheck. Come on.
It's just you and make, whoa. What did
she, what, what, what'd you do? You know,
I imagine if she fucked around on
you, you would've mentioned it. Yeah.
Okay.
All right. Maybe I'm taking these fucking
songs a little too seriously. Um, I,
I have a problem with that. Like when I
listen to rap music, you know, like who?
Suzette new group that
everybody's Migos. When I,
when I watch their videos and shit and
they've coming up in those supercars and
they're holding the fucking
money out, it just, it literally,
I have to look in the other direction.
It just drives me not seeing
artists doing that. I just,
I'm always thinking in my head,
please, please buy some real estate.
Please don't blow it all
on fucking Coby eleven's.
Oh my God, Dude.
Watch an artist's watch and people
who don't understand money I guess.
But I would say artists, you
know the shit that we fucking do.
It's just the dumbest,
you know what's another
stupid fucking thing?
I love these people that buy watches
that are like you. It's like dude,
that thing you could hang
that on the fucking wall.
I'd know what time it
was from across the room.
Why do you have that on
that roof on your wrist?
The amount of guys that are like my
height and my size walking around with a
watch that only would look right on
like a fucking offensive lineman is,
it's like, did you take
that out of a submarine? Is,
is that like deep sea scuba dive and
Shit so you can [inaudible] you can go
fucking go down to like what?
9,000 feet now with the,
the Goddamn dial won't bust on it.
I got my big old watch.
People in a different time zone can
tell what time it is. Take this walk.
I can show that pro flowers everybody.
Have you ever forgotten your
anniversary? If you're not nodding yes,
you're lying.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. What the fuck is this?
I don't forget my anniversary. It
gets up to, I'm not gonna lie to you.
It definitely sneaks up on me where
I'll be off pockets in two days.
What can I get or what can I get or I
don't have time. Maybe I'll get, uh,
some fucking flowers. Um, you know those
people that are just hard to shop for?
Like your wife, for your anniversary,
your sister for a birthday.
It's just the worst. Trying to
find that gift. A, you don't know.
You don't know.
I think that's supposed to say what
you don't know what the like and B.
[inaudible]
what? It's just the worst. Trying
to, okay. It's just the worst.
Trying to find a gift at
a, you know, they'll like,
and B won't cost an arm and a leg.
Well, I'm going to make it easy for you.
Pro Flowers is my go to for flowers.
It's actually a flower store down
the street. That's my fucking go to.
I hate the Internet. You know,
I'll go on there and I'll try to click
on something and next thing you know,
I'll eat the, either the or they
either won't go through all,
I'll have enough fucking
funeral to re up enough funeral.
flowers to rebury Elvis.
That's what I was trying to say. Then
I just started picturing his funeral.
Anyways, pro flowers is
my go to for flowers.
They're fresh price, right, and a
perfect gift for literally anyone.
Oh yeah. Get one for your guy
friends. That's a fucking gift.
If you just want to freak out
one of your fucking friends,
just get us some flowers and have the car.
Just say thinking of you and then
you write in parentheses, smile
and they get delivered straight
to your recipient store.
How easy is that at right now?
Go to pro flowers right now.
Pro Flowers has a special gift
offer. A just for our listeners,
get $10 off your
purchases for $29 or more.
10 bucks off for any purchase of $29 a
month. Pro Flower bouquets or bouquets,
police or police are guaranteed fresh
for seven days of your money back.
They have seven step quality check, which
means the flowers are always awesome.
Your website is super easy to use.
You can schedule your delivery ahead of
time for any date you want and get you
and get back to your day.
Pro Flowers is a no brainer gift for
a birthday and an anniversary every
occasion or even for no occasion
at all. Anytime when you want to,
he monitor to feel special. They
key. If you don't want you woman,
my wall dawn left me so I've got some
pro flowers planted them and are taught.
They take care of all the details.
Do yourself a favor and to help out the
show by supporting pro flowers. I know,
uh, I know you have either a birthday
or your anniversary coming up.
Well everybody does. If
you wait long enough.
So right now I'll get $10 $10 off your
purchases for $29 or more at pro flowers.
But this deal definitely won't last long.
Just go to pro flowers.com and enter
the code burr at checkout to get this
special deal.
I was wondering why they were going to
be advertising flowers this time of year.
I was like, what are you
gonna get it for fucking East?
Get some Ash Wednesday flowers.
Why are they advertising it?
Cause you know what, they
probably had their maximum appeal.
They probably hit their maximum fucking,
I just realized it's probably somebody
sleeping on the other side. I mean,
I'm waking them up with my fucking Johnny
paycheck saying, let me get over here.
Um, anyways, so they'd
probably be like, well,
how can we get people that fucking
buy flowers all year round?
How can we create a need?
Everybody's got an anniversary.
Everybody's got a birthday
birthday, right? Hey,
I like the way you're thinking Carl.
We could sell flowers to hoe he around.
Um, all right. stamps.com everybody
the hassle,
man of the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease.
No longterm commitments,
um, with no lease,
no equipment to lease and
no longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for lettuce or packages
at your convenience. 24, seven,
seven days a week. Stamps saw
calm, brings all the surfaces,
services of the US Postal Service,
right your fingertips buy and print
official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps.com will help you
decide the best class
of mail on your needs.
No need to lease an
expensive postage meter. Um,
I use stamps.com anytime
I've got posters, you know,
I'm going to whore myself
out after shows. Um,
which I haven't done in a
minute, but I'm, you know,
I'm thinking I'm going to start fucking
doing that again. Now that I'm a father.
Now that I got my daughter, my
daughter, don't let me, don't go.
The reason I'm okay right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps service
with a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without a longterm commitment.
Um, go to stamps.com. Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible].
All right, I'm getting up against it
here. You know what I'm doing today,
by the way, I'm going
to go see, oh Cleo Odeo.
I'm going to see my dog Cleo. Um, the,
the people that ended up, uh,
rescue getting her from
us live out here. So, um,
I'm actually gonna get to see her. I'm
visiting her today and tomorrow and, um,
I can't wait to see her in everything.
She's probably not going to give a shit
cause she's probably gonna be so
in love with the other people.
Cause I kinda realized that going well.
She was in love with the people that
had her before us and within a week she
fucking loved us. I mean, dogs should
they adapt, they just fucking adept. So,
um, I've got another five minutes
here and then I, I gotta take off.
So I got time for like one question
here. Let me see. Um, let me get,
let me get a good one here. Uh, Alrighty.
Rady a dictator bill.
I'm 19 years old and I've been with
my girlfriend, my Wallman Dolan left.
I'm with my girlfriend
now for two years. Uh,
I know what you're thinking too
young for all these silly problems.
That's not what I'm thinking. I'm thinking
good for you. Way To go where to go.
Fell. Um, anyway, for the
first year of our relationship,
literally everything was perfect. I still
love her just as much as I did then.
I'm sure she loves me
just as much. However,
during the second year of our relationship
relationship and overnight shift
changed.
Yeah.
Um, and then we stopped
having sex it based,
it's basically nonexistent
and now and again,
every couple of months it will happen.
But I know she's not enjoying it.
This is because she was on the
implant contraception injection.
At first I was questioning myself and
if it was me that wasn't getting her in
the mood anymore, but she promises me
that it isn't because of the implant.
She says it's that what the fuck
is a contraception injection?
[inaudible] okay. Oh Jesus. I,
I didn't mean I've never
heard of that shit.
Okay.
It's an injection so you
won't get pregnant. Dude,
if you literally told me contraception
actually meant it's going to get you
pregnant, I would believe
that too. This week.
One of those fucking words that I
just ignored my whole life. You know,
like Soliloquy, like what the fuck does
that mean? You know, contraception,
implant
official site. Get the facts. Fuck that.
I don't want facts. I want pictures.
Images.
Okay. They're showing it
that it's nice and small.
For some reason they keep
putting it up against the bicep.
They stick it in your fucking arm
watch.
So say some fucking robot shit. Okay.
It's birth control implant.
They stick a fucking toothpick in your
arm and then you can't have a baby.
I don't get it. Anyways. Well yeah,
that's probably fucking annoying to
have it in there. You know what I mean?
She goes to hug you in the
inside of her arm hurts. Anyways,
after the first I was
questioning [inaudible],
she says that that is caused her
to completely lose her sex drive.
She says she just had it removed and it's
been a few weeks since and nothing has
changed yet.
I feel so much resentment towards her
every day and what I can only describe as
depression. As soon as I see her,
most of the time I find myself being
such an angry short tempered person.
Now when normally I'm
usually happy and smiling,
a Jesus might be time to get
out of this relationship buddy.
But you know something, if it
really affected her like that,
it depends on how long
she had it in there.
Maybe she needs longer than
two weeks. Um, but you know,
if you're going to be an angry lunatic,
I mean if you don't leave eventually
she's gonna. But you know what,
you get yourself a song on a warm
dawn port a to pick in her arm.
Now she won't suck my
Dick one of these days.
I'm going to whip it out
and wipe it on the wall.
You can take mod dick and shove it, um,
Rodney and your fucking mouth,
you whore. But do, do, do, do.
But do you do okay? I always try.
I always seem to try and hide my need
for sex and act like I don't ever want it
and tried to show
disinterests but I never can.
I guess it just must be more
important to me than it is to her.
I never thought sex was such a big deal,
but the last year has taught me
that when there's bad sex life in a
relationship, it can really cause
the whole thing to just break down.
It just got to the point now that I've
said we need some space and a break,
cause the last thing I want is
to ruin our relationship. Um,
dude, you're fucking miserable man.
And you have to, you have to, you know,
it's, you gotta be with somebody and
like understand them and, and you know,
be there when they're going through
a tough time, but like, you know,
if they're not understanding how fucking
miserable you are, you're just gonna.
You just going to keep getting
more miserable and then, you know,
then they're going to be
miserable. And then in the end,
they're gonna fucking break up with you
and you're gonna be like, what the fuck?
I should have done that to them.
I'm not breaking up with somebody.
It's not something you should do to them.
It's something you should do for yourself.
All right? This is the deal, dude.
You're not fucking happy.
All right? You're not happy.
It's great that you've
taken a fucking break.
And I would go out and I'd fucking go try
to enjoy myself and meet somebody that
doesn't have a fucking toothpick in
their arm that doesn't want to touch my
dick. You know? I mean, that's just
getting down to brass tacks here.
That's what's going on, right?
They stuck that shit in her and a,
you can't stick your shit in hurt. So
I mean, why you gotta get the fuck out?
I get out. You're young, dude, you're
19. What are you gonna marry her?
What do you in the military? People in
the military get married when they're 19,
you know?
Okay.
But, and dawn left, um,
that's what you do. I,
it's just sounds like
a, you sound like you,
you need like a long time away from
each other. The way that was read, dude,
that sounded like a fucking 40
year old guy rather that Indian 19.
So that's kind of a good sign that maybe
she get the fuck out. Um, who knows?
But I, I would not say anything mean
I would not. And uh, I just, you know,
you want to be able to see the person
again and not get a glass to the head.
You know what I mean? That's
kind of what you're going for.
So the art form is you just
tell them how you're feeling.
Yeah.
You know, I'm just not happy. I'm
sorry. That's just how I feel.
I'm just not happy and I'm finding
myself less and less happy and,
um, it's affecting my moods.
Everything you just said.
Okay.
And I'm finding that I'm getting angry
and I don't want to be angry around you
and create any misery in your life. So
as much as this is going to hurt you,
I'm walking out the door, you
can take this relationship,
shove it. Um,
okay.
That's it. They walk
out the door, you know,
and you'll probably walk out that door
and you'd be sad a little bit and your
walk a little more.
Then you start skipping and then you're
running down the street. Yeah, yeah.
It might be one of those breakups or it
could be the one, oh, why did I do it?
I don't fucking know. But you're
19, you know, if you got the whole,
you got your whole fucking life ahead
of you. You don't need to be in this.
This sounds like you're fucking married.
I'd get up. All right. That's it. Okay.
And that's the fucking podcast
for this week. Go fuck yourselves.
I will check in on you
on, I'm on Thursday.
And uh, that said,
I'll let you know how she and all
clear the next couple of days is,
which is going to be fucking
awesome. And it's also, you know,
and I'm psyched that, you know,
we've got a cool family and uh,
you know, I think I'll come out to
Phoenix a couple times a year, you know,
do a run of shows like I'm doing here.
Go to a game or something like that,
I'll hang out with the dog. It's kind
of Nice, you know? All right. That's it.
I'll talk to you guys on Thursday.